this photograph of Marcy borders came to
symbolize the collective trauma New
Yorkers experienced on September 11th
2001
she was nicknamed the dust lady she died
two weeks ago of stomach cancer at the
age of 42 photographers Stan Honda who
took the picture encountered miss
borders in the building next to the
World Trade Center after it collapsed
this woman walks in and completely
covered and dust you really couldn't see
any features or tell what kind of
clothes she got on anything like that it
was very eerie sight and I had only
enough time to take one picture of her
one frame
Susan hair barely escaped the disaster
she was working in a bank on the 68th
floor of tower two she remembers the
moment the first plane struck I got in
an elevator that wasn't supposed to be
working and took it down to the lobby
there I tried to get out onto the plaza
but they had blocked it off and I found
that late it was because the people were
jumping out of Tower 1 I went to get out
on to Greenwich and a police woman told
me don't look down just run as Susan
hare ran she nearly tripped on body
parts she's still haunted by the memory
this is the first time she's found the
strength to return to this spot it took
tremendous effort since the 9/11 attacks
she has suffered from post-traumatic
stress and asthma she's also a cancer
survivor without public assistance she
would never have been able to pay her
medical bills
but the 2.8 billion dollar fund
supported by the James Zadroga 9/11
health and Compensation Act named after
one of the first responders is set to
run out at the end of the year it's very
important to me and to the fellow
survivors of 9/11 the aid that we get
from the Sagara bill helps us pay our
medical bills and also networks us with
a whole bunch of
there's that a familiar with the nine
eleven illnesses both physical and
emotional and mentally one of the
specialists who's treated many 9/11
survivors is dr. Michael crane he's
concerned about what might happen if the
aid program is terminated the
interruption of that care while no
physician to my knowledge would abandon
a patient would eventually lead in a
district to a disruption of the services
at a very critical moment and it could
be yes it could be a tremendous setback
for many of our patients who are being
treated for these critical diseases
that's a view shared by Margaret chin a
democratic representative of the New
York City Council she fears that
Congress in a cost-cutting measure could
slash funding handing responsibility to
New York
we just want Congress to know this is
not a New York issue this is a national
issue because the people that came to
help to do the rescue effort they came
from almost every single state in the
United States Susan hair will be
dependent on public health assistance
for years to come
if Congress ends the funding she and
thousands of other New Yorkers will be
left in the lurch